from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between mcdonald's in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
hey guys joe from food wars we're doing
a new season we're comparing the u.s to
japan in order to do that i want to
introduce you to co-host and my man in
japan george hello guys i'm george i'm
from japan and i like mcdonald's
[Music]
so in japan our mcdonald's sodas come in
three sizes this is small
small
and this is japan's medium
medium
and this one is japan's large large
in japan our chicken mcnuggets come in 5
and 15 pieces
our chicken mcnuggets come in 4
6
10
20 or 40 piece
look at all those nuggets
oh they've been sitting for a while
japan mcdonald's fries come in three
sizes small medium and large in the u.s
you get your fries in four sizes kids
small
medium and large
this little guy
look at this little guy
so this is largest fries and i'm gonna
weight them we are going to also weigh a
large mcdonald's fry
wow
okay so so far our largest are the same
yeah wow that worked perfectly the thing
i just did there great job joe
go home
go
now let's measure the medium why not
our mediums are smaller
interesting so this is a japanese big
mug
[Music]
so this is a japanese big mac this is an
american big mac and we're going to
weigh it as well
now we've got a heftier big mac here in
the u.s
it's more like it
in japan the big mac value set which is
a big mix
and medium fries and a medium drink
comes out to 690 yen or six dollars 21
cents
in the u.s that same meal costs
8.54 cents or
948.46 japanese yen that's a
37.52 increase in price in the us
what the heck
so here is everything you can only get
at japan's mcdonald's you can not get in
the u.s and this is everything you can
get at a u.s mcdonald's that you cannot
get in japan so we're gonna start with
waffle cons right here so we got plain
so plain means it's like rich milk taste
and next one is strawberry strawberry
personally i like this and next one is
chocolate and almond
right there
it's not melting good job buddy so here
we've got mcflows so much fruits means
there is soda and on top of that there's
ice cream that's it that's it and this
is mac fruits melon
itadakimasu
it's too sweet
this is great coffee mug floats
and the last one we've got coke mcfloats
oh
joe
you'll definitely try this
yes
absolutely i'm trying that when i go to
japan that looks real good let me think
here hang on a second
okay
we do not have mcfloats here in the u.s
so i'm going to make my own on the way
over here i was looking for grape soda
it's actually harder to find than i
thought fanta is not very popular in the
united states but we got this
this is
midnight grape kickstarter mountain dew
it's grape
[Music]
ha ha left over from the ben and jerry
shoot stuff is frozen there we go
[Music]
yeah
i'm into this
these would do well in the u.s
our cold drinks a little bit different
uh we have two exclusive slushies that
you can't get in japan one is pink
lemonade strawberry watermelon yeah dude
it looks real good yes they do have
mcflurries and ice cream in japan the
one mcflurry you can get in the u.s is
this one an m m's mcflurry
sorry
it's
since melted but it's like those uh
those mini m m's i went to one of the
few mcdonald's in the country where the
ice cream machine was working hot
caramel sundae and
the classic
fudge sundae
so let's go with soft drinks right here
found the grape
and here is fanta melon
and this one is japanese vegetable juice
and there is
i guess more than 20 or 30 vegetables in
it and it's good for health for sure
itadakimasu
we've got
cool white grape so can be so can we
just like a japanese blended tea
it's healthy and japanese people drink
this on a daily basis so next one we've
got
earl grey iced tea let me show you
wait
there is something
there's a mosquito
i have to make a complaint japan
mcdonald's
next one we've got
tea
so this is not actually japanese tea
it's a chinese tea that's good for
health as well
for health we do have
a mango pineapple smoothie
and a banana strawberry smoothie
smoothies have fruit in it right
oh yeah
i can just feel the nutrients coursing
through my veins
so let's start with this hawaiian menu
this is limited this one right here is
cheese locomotive
oh it's messy
it's a damn glass sauce
man and it's also got
round egg right there
beef patty and some cheese
i'm hungry actually
oh this is good
oh
this is home to niumai which means
really really delicious
first next one we've got garlic shrimp
and it's also got
interesting bun
there is sesame on there and um deep
fried shrimp
hawaiian barbecue potato and beef
demi-glass sauce again
it's gonna be good
this is called barbecue burger right but
i don't taste burping cattle alright so
next one we've got hawaiian pancake with
triple berry sauce two pancakes
mmm
smells so sweet
let's go
[Music]
too sweet
mac face blue hawaii
wow
it has bright blue color
this is mac face cassis and orange
i will get this i will get this so
congratulations this is the worst
okay
breakfast time this is a breakfast
burrito oh neon yellow egg
mexican style salsa
not to be confused with what canadian
salsa
this is actually the same burrito from
the us uk thing we shot over a year ago
so let's go on to these breakfast
sandwiches here japan does have the
mcgriddles which are favorite of mine so
unfortunately we will not be talking
about those today
sad face i love you mcgriddles
so what they don't have and also the uk
did not have were our breakfast biscuit
sandwiches i don't know how to describe
a biscuit other than
it's dry
it's baked
maybe they're made with cornmeal
according to the internet this is not a
scone so there you go sausage egg and
cheese
our egg is like this fluffy folded
scrambled egg egg so there's like sunny
side up ours are scrambled i can tell
this was like folded over you can see
like the fold lines there this is how we
do in the u.s bacon egg and cheese is
there a better breakfast combination in
the world i don't think there is then
they just have the sausage
no egg no cheese just sausage and
biscuit
we have regular sized hotcakes and we
have a hot cake and sausage combo of
course
it comes with syrup
and
butter
very natural pose
very natural feeling right now always up
for report yes
breakfast is served
oatmeal on the side to be mixed in
cranberries and raisins and
diced oh
diced
apples here we've got
mega muffin
pork patties that's huge one
mini pancakes
oh cute
it comes with apple cream sauce
[Music]
this is perfect for breakfast i will get
it
bacon egg mac sandwich so it's got
bacon
and round egg and cheddar cheese
that's it
and you might be surprised we've got
phil fish
ta-da
so phil fish is on the breakfast menu i
guess japanese people tend to eat fish
for breakfast three exclusive burgers
here in the us are variations on the
quarter pounder with cheese yes we've
all seen pulp fiction we know about the
whole quarter ponder thing does not
exist outside of the u.s i don't think
so probably why they don't have quarter
ponders in japan
the classic quarter pounder with cheese
look at this guy i mean this was maybe
my go-to one for
a decade
the quarter pounder with cheese deluxe i
don't know
i feel like this is pretty close to a
whopper i'm not a big whopper guy but
there you go
a deluxe quarter pounder with cheese
the double quarter powder with cheese
look at the size of this thing
yes
sir
japan's exclusive burgers teriyaki mug
burger which is my most
favorite one
my body is made of
bacteria butter
[Laughter]
so it's got a mayo right there and
lettuce pork patties dip it into
delicious terry excels and it's covering
whole pork patties perfectly
joe when you come to japan please try
this you will thank me later
everything that they have looks so good
and sounds so good man when i go to
tokyo
first stop i'm going to mcdonald's sushi
ramen get it out of my face i want the
teriyaki burger that's the first thing
i'm getting when i get there
i'm getting full actually
i'm looking for boob
slide on george we got a lot of food to
cover
welcome to food was baby
alright so we've got
bacon lettuce burger right here
it looks sad
egg cheeseburger but we also call it
eguchi egg is an abbreviation for egg
cheeseburger japanese people love
abbreviation it's got ketchup and pickle
round egg and cheddar cheese and beef
patties
next one spicy beef burger oh look at
this oh it looks so spicy you spicy mayo
or something like that so here we've got
samurai muk
samurai
samurai mac
yo
that sounds awesome and this blue one is
called
roasted soy sauce double thick beef
we've got
roasted soy sauce bacon tomato thick
beef so if you want a little bit more
like healthy veggies
go for it
uh yeah george i don't know if that
makes that much healthier there because
it also has twice as much meat and
cheese if you're looking to be healthy
at a mcdonald's in japan i'd stick with
the vegetable juice and this one right
here is called
carrier key chicken filet o wow so much
sauce so next one we've got eb philio
abby means shrimp so it's a shrimp filet
o
oh yeah it's got oral sauce ora sauce is
like a ketchup and mayonnaise
so it's got a lot of shrimp in there
hmm
so good so good in the u.s we have about
four uh exclusive chicken sandwiches
specifically i didn't see this on the
menu but apparently you guys don't have
a mcchicken
which is just chicken sandwich
uh regular bun
mayo
chicken
[Music]
yeah
we also have
check this out
spicy mcchicken
so pretty much the same with chicken but
like they put spicy coating on the
breading on the chicken every fast food
chain in america right now is having
what we're calling the fried chicken
sandwich wars popeyes uh burger king of
course mcdonald's all of them are at
this arms race to have the best chicken
sandwich i think cause chick-fil-a's
edged everyone out these are the three
that are currently available i don't
know for how long there's a crispy
chicken sandwich things as a brioche bun
uh pickles
and no sauce which i think is strange
like the whole flavor is just
just the chicken spicy
chicken sandwich same deal but of course
spicy sauce
and the spicy chicken deluxe which to
george's point has more vegetables on it
you know to be healthier
okay so when it comes to side menus
we've got shaka shaka chicken
and we have
two flavors oh
two flavors can you hear that
sunder thunder thunder because it's
raining season in japan
the sunny season here in southern
california
and here is red pepper
and this one is cheddar cheese
[Music]
founder stop
so all you have to do is just put the
powder into the back
and
shake it
and the powder should be covering the
whole shotgun chicken
big one
like this
this i've seen before this i want that's
the thing i want the most of the
japanese mcdonald's us mcdonald's we
have the bags we have the chicken just
get the spice packets throw one in
we've got
side salad
and it comes with this
roasted sesame dressing let's go
oh was cool
now put it all in the garbage we've got
edamame and corn
yogurt
and there is
cow
cow
exclusive sauces it's sauce talk time
sauce talk
we have sweet and sour sauce they gave
me
hot mustard
this would be honey mustard you guys
have hot mustard i know you don't have
honey mustard of course ranch uh ooh
spicy buffalo
now these might be promotions because of
that uh
singing group bts
but we have right now a
cajun sauce and a sweet chili sauce this
sauce is
fantastic this is the sauce this has to
stay in the morning so these two are new
ones
this one right here is
soy sauce based sauce
man this is fantastic good job very good
taste
so this one right here is called
louisiana jostos oh
it does look like very spicy one
[Music]
this is not spicy at all
actually we were supposed to have buy
burger options but unfortunately you can
only get them from 5 30 p.m but let me
explain what by burger is
bai simply means double in japanese so
if you order a normal big mug it has two
big patties right but if you order buy
big mug it has four beef patties but not
only big mac but all burgers and adopts
the buy burger options that's funny you
can only get double the meat after 5 30.
that's really funny that would not stand
in this country at all people would lose
their minds
four
i once big mac
so after shooting this video i'm gonna
order buy big mug and then buy by health
you ain't gotta tell me george bye
health
all right here are all the ingredients
for u.s big mac oh god the bun it has
enriched flour which is wheat flour
vinegar and contains wheat onto the beef
patty 100 pure usda inspected beef no
fillers no extenders prepared on the
grill with seasoning salt and black
pepper there you go there you go
shredded lettuce ingredients lettuce
nice the big mac sauce ingredients
soybean oil
[Laughter]
extractives of paprika soy lecithin
the pickle slice ingredients cucumbers
water distilled vinegar salt calcium
chloride alum potassium sorbates
preservative natural flavors
polysorbidae extractives of turmeric for
color onion ingredients onions there you
go
a few things i want to note alum is used
to dissolve steel
holly's orbit 80 has been linked to
colon cancer and mice cue the dancing
mice
and caramel color is on california's
list of chemicals that may cause cancer
and reproductive toxicity good good
counterpoint they all taste fantastic so
mcdonald's japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients in the big mug however they
do tell us where the ingredients come
from if you order a big mug in japan
you'll eat beef from australia or new
zealand
buns made from wheat imported from the
usa canada and australia
and pickles made from cucumbers grown in
turkey sri lanka or india
onions grown in the usa or india
sliced cheddar cheese made in new
zealand australia the usa or japan
and lettuce grown in japan taiwan the
usa or malaysia
the only ingredients that come from
japan are the cheese and the lettuce
and even then mcdonald's still imports
some lettuce and cheese from other
countries so this is a very
international burger
thank you world
so in japan our big mac is 525 calories
and 28.3 grams of fat
and
1007 milligrams of sodium and 41.8 grams
of carbs and 26 grams of protein in the
us our big mac is
550 calories 30 grams of fat 1010
milligrams of sodium 45 grams of carbs
and 25 grams of protein so the u.s has a
slight increase on everything except
protein
so in japan our five piece nuggets is
270 calories and 17.2 grams of fat and
506 milligrams of sodium and 13.1 grams
of carbs and 15.8 grams of protein
broken down each nugget is 54 calories
we don't have a five piece here in the
us but we do have this a 10 piece let's
get those stats on the screen go ahead
and divide everything by two and yes now
we have the stats for a five piece
pretty smart eh if we want to divide all
that by i think five you'll get the
stats for one nugget
this is so exhausting
in japan if you order a big mac meal
with large fries and a medium chocolate
shake the grand total will be
1405 calories in in the u.s adding
medium fries and a medium chocolate
shake to a big mac the grand total is
1660 calories and that is a calorie
increase of 18.14
if you're wondering why we're using a
large fried but a medium chocolate shake
turns out that in japan you can't get a
large chocolate shake the only salty and
medium i'm assuming because i don't want
you eating that much ice cream
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between cafes in japan and the u.s
this is food awards
so the fries at the cafes in japan come
in three sizes so this is small
and next one is back again
then we've got
a box
now let's weigh our largest prize
[Laughter]
i'm shook as the kids say by that
information i want to say though that
theirs is like a box that thing is like
made to be eaten by more than one person
i'm assuming but this clearly this is
for a person so in japan we have three
drink sizes so we have a small
in the us our drinks come in medium
and we got a large large
so in japan cafe doesn't disclose how
much liquid is in each of the sizes why
so i will help you kelsey we will
measure the cups right now let's go
so now let's measure our large and just
to make sure it's accurate we didn't
clean the measuring cup
go home
so at the cafes in japan you can order
your chicken pieces in one piece two
pieces three
pieces
four pieces
and six pieces
and eight pieces
and 10 pieces
and
12 pieces
kfc in the u.s our chicken portion sizes
start as a two-piece combo by the way
come on guys this isn't whatever
whatever it's supposed to be then the
three piece right in front of me here
that's the exact opposite i went extra
crispy for this look at the size of
these chicken pieces yes
yes to these and the four piece this is
somewhere in the middle and each combo
comes with a biscuit your choice of
potato either fries or mashed with gravy
and all of them come with a medium drink
but we don't stop there we go now to
buckets where you can get an eight-piece
bucket
12-piece bucket or 16-piece bucket
so now we are going to weigh our 8-piece
chicken to compare the weights in each
country
oh
yo
it's pretty close considering all the
variables of
size of chicken
bone density
batter
i don't know what i'm talking about but
that's surprisingly close so in japan a
two piece of original chicken which are
breast and wing and small fries and a
medium drink cost 800 yen or 7.27
so japan actually kfc is considered a
little bit more expensive compared to
other fast food chains like mcdonald's
so it's a classic fast food in japan
that same meal is about
8.99 or in japanese yen
992.27 so that's about a 24 cost
increase in the us in japan to make
chicken at kfc you must be certified as
a chicken specialist and certification
takes three months and your knowledge
and skills are tested every year alright
so let's take chicken specialist test
right now
right george let's do this number one
for the original chicken 100 percent
domestic that's kind
[Music]
head on this one i don't even know what
that means all right so just now i've
got all of the five answers so let's
check the answers gold chicken
circulation
[Applause]
says not kfc material it's a picture of
colonel sanders giving me the finger so
i'm gonna assume i did not pass it but
anyway i've got a goal
i'm the champion
i am very surprised by that i think i
could work for kfc i mean i kind of look
like colonel sanders right look at this
guy
i'm a younger colonel sanders kfc is
doing any sort of the adventures of
young colonel sanders ad campaign
is this a face they can sell chicken
yeah haven't you guys ever read the
secret i'm putting the energy that i
want out into the universe and it comes
back to me
and it's called manifesting
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at the cafes in japan but
not in the us and here is everything you
can find and the menu in a us kfc you
cannot get in japan here we've got
cafe biscuits both places have biscuits
but their biscuit has a hole in it it
looks a lot fluffier right our biscuit
on the other hand is just this southern
style not exactly a scone but kind of
looks like one from a distance dry
cornmeal biscuit it comes with honey
maple cafe
this is good the maple is a little bit
sweet for me mac and cheese i can't
believe you guys do not have macaroni
and cheese
love mac and cheese mashed potatoes and
gravy you don't have that in japan guys
guys demand this from your japanese kfc
you want the mashed potatoes and gravy
so we also have
deep packs
it's got kernel crispy
um some nuggets
and boneless kentucky
and some original chicken so this deep
pack it comes with this price and also
these
three dipping sauces
and now for the quickest sauce talk ever
saute kfc sauce
i think the kfc sauce is like a brown
mustard mayo yeah that sauce is good so
we've got
barbecue sauce and
mustard and this pink one is called
mentaiko mayo mentaiko means is like
spicy cod roll and very popular taste in
japan this is actually great i'll dip
this
it tastes fantastic winner
so if you want to have a little bigger
one you can order deep burial i mean
it's double amount of this deep pack so
it's gonna be very big so this one right
here is called four piece red hot
chicken box and it comes with a pie
and fry
and the medium drink and actually we
have other box options like four piece
half hot and half original box and it
comes with fries as well and
six piece half hot and half original box
it comes with fries again
so in japan we have tori no
that means chicken day it's on every
28th of the month and two stands for ni
and eight stands for
and it becomes niwa and niwa is
synonymous with newaturi newa 3 means
so that's why it's called chicken day
kfc in america
has
extra crispy chicken this is the best
type of chick i mean look at this i
don't know what they do to this but the
skin is practically falling off is so
crispy and so delicious i love extra
crispy so much i got this little guy
the chicken little look at this guy huh
that's a little guy comes with pickles
mayo the pot pie that they have here
they're not kidding when they say pie in
the pot pie how thick this is speaking
of big dishes of stuff the famous bowl
once upon a time a kfc employee was like
i could have put everything into one
dish and call it a day and ta-da the
famous bowl was born this has to be like
three pounds all right so here we've got
two special twisters so this one right
here is called
pepper mayonnaise twister
[Music]
it looks great
nine out of ten kfc
thank you thank you for making me happy
so next we got ooh
teriyaki twister
should be great
it's kind of gross
it's got mayo and kernel crispy some
veggies and i hope this is teriyaki
sauce
it looks gross but it tastes
incredible 10 out of 10. congratulations
it means delicious look how tiny those
twisters are i could eat like three of
those easily easily all right so we have
nuggets we have
three pieces
five pieces and they come with only
ketchup also the uskfc that you can't
get in japan are wings you can get wings
at the kfc and units of 6 12 24 or 48. i
believe the three wing flavors that i
got here are standard buffalo
the
honey barbecue and if you're a total
wuss
on sauce what's wrong with you yeah very
sketchy you can also get them in a
limited time nashville hot sauce now we
have special sandwiches this one right
here is called japanese style chicken
cut sandwich so let's take a look inside
it's got mayo and it's got cabbage and
chicken cuts right there
oh
this sauce is like soy sauce-based sauce
and it's a little bit sweet and this
mayo is also great with the sauce this
looks really small but
it has huge amount of chicken so if you
eat this you're gonna be full
and next one
we've got chicken fillet
wow this is also huge all right so this
one right here is called black hot
sandwich
[Music]
look at this it's like pepper mayo i
just tasted this paper mayo but it has a
little like spiciness oh
man it's too strong i wouldn't get it be
careful now of course the u.s has a
chicken sandwich but our chicken
sandwich and their chicken sandwich as
you can see is way different you can
also get it spicy or classic this is
classic all right so this one right here
is called chrono crispy is it only in
japan i cannot confirm the difference
between a kernel crispy and a kfc
chicken tender they call their tenders
kernel crispies and we call our colonel
crispies chicken tenders
it's been a while since i ordered this
one
but it still has
crispy bits
good job japanese kfc's technology state
of the art we currently have a nashville
hot chicken and hot tenders i went ahead
with the tenders i've just been informed
this was a big tick tock thing for a
minute something about biting and
crunching it i don't know anything about
that i can say just by holding this
there's no way these are crispy
well it's not that spicy that's kind of
spicy i do like this a lot
i'm gonna stop eating them
oh that's catching up with me
slow burn slow builds on the heat so
here we've got japanese exclusive drinks
this one right here
is
water right
but
it comes with this assam tea pack
it's supposed to be hot but it's cold
and next one we've got coffee this one
right here is rusted rich coffee
it's a little bit better than that
normal coffee and here we got
all gray iced tea it's not sweet at all
and next one is melon soda it has bright
green color
horrible it's too sweet here is ginger
ale nothing special and the last one is
nacho refreshing orange fountain drinks
there's a few that we can get that you
guys cannot over there in japan the
first one is a beverage that i have yet
to make one human being who enjoys it
of course i'm talking about sierra mist
maybe grossest soda ever
oh it's so bad another drink that you
can get at kfc that you can't get at
japan and here it is right here mountain
is great when i was in college i worked
at a pizza place i drink so much
mountain dew i threw up and now i'm
drinking mountain dew let's see if i can
do it again my favorite beverage
mountain dew sweet lightning
so good so good the drinks are just
normal nothing special but chickens
are
finger licking good
dessert to the us kfc you can get this
chocolate chip cookie recognize that guy
it just looks just like this guy
and finally a chocolate chip cake
so let's talk about christmas in japan
so christmas is one of the biggest
events in japan even though about one
percent of japanese people are
christians we just enjoy christmas as
just a fun event and as for kfc for
christmas in japan back in
1970s japan kfc launched a hugely
successful advertising campaign
called kentuckino christmas that's
kentucky for christmas and with that
strong marketing campaign it became so
popular to have kfc for christmas in
japan and now about 3.6 million japanese
families eat caffeine for christmas and
talking about my personal experiences
yes when i was young i would eat
caffeine for christmas with my family
but when you started dating you know
christmas makes the transformation from
a family event to couples event and i'm
looking for the one who can enjoy kfc
for christmas
with me
in japan one drum stick of
so in japan one drum stick of original
chicken on average has 237 calories
chicken's looking a little limp there
george in the u.s one stiff drumstick of
original recipe is 130 calories but
according to kfc's u.s site that's for a
53 gram piece now adjusting for the 87
gram piece like that of japan the
calories go up to
210. does that make sense great now take
this bad boy and make them extra crispy
you got 270 calories so japan have two
pieces of original chickens and a small
fry and dummy drink is roughly
717 calories
a u.s two-piece individual fry and
medium drink comes out to be 990
calories so a lot more it's too many
calories mmm
not enough calories if you ask me but
finger licking good i think kfc got to
george he keeps dropping that slogan are
they paying george i think i think
george is getting some money on the side
from kfc oh my god if the george turns
out to be colonel sanders i will lose my
mind
so kfc in japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support and this is what they told us
in the us our original recipe chicken
ingredients are first with the fresh
chicken it is marinated with salt sodium
phosphate and monosodium glutamate onto
the breading it's breaded with wheat
flour like calcium phosphate
maltodextrin triglycerides natural
flavor kernels secret original recipe
seasoning they also said our fries are
made of potatoes obviously and vegetable
oil and what the butter is made of rice
flour vegetables
and dextrose and our fries which contain
sea salt monosodium glutamate try
calcium phosphate hydrolyzed soy protein
potassium chloride potatoes salts good d
germs yellow cornmeal sodium
dihydrogen pyrophosphate to maintain
natural color what's more natural than
disodium diohydrin pyrophosphate rolls
up the tongue and one thing i have to
say is that our fries are imported from
both america and belgium and some of the
belgium fries are made with potatoes
from france so our fries are truly truly
french
bonjour
in the u.s we have four chicken shapes
in japan we have five chicken shapes let
me explain so we have this one it's
called kale kale is like
chicken's breath
right here
i'm going to say chicken's chest
[Music]
heel is like
chicken's chest right there
first one is the breast this is the big
piece of chicken your dad gets and also
we got wing it's a as you know chicken
wing
this is supposed to be a wing this is
laughably small and we got this one it's
called rib chickens have ribs so rib is
like
under the chest
right here and we got this one thigh
thigh is like chicken's lower back
and the next piece is this which i think
is the thigh and of course
the next piece everyone knows the drum
and this is a chicken's leg
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between starbucks in japan and the us
this is food wars
in japan our hot coffee comes in four
sizes
short
short coal
tall
grande
the grande
and vendi
and of course living
mmm
[Music]
starbucks episode i'm taking a sip of
everything in japan our iced coffee
comes in four sizes
short so we start with vital
toll too good and
grande grande
and benti now when we get to the ice
venti size it gets a little bit
different so our ice venti ain't 20 it's
24 ounces and then we have a bigger size
the trenta
which is 30 fluid ounces for your iced
coffee aficionados who also hate your
bladder this is the one for you so in
japan we have this handy coffee traveler
it's 12 cups of coffee so you just take
this off and set the cup right here
itadakimasu
i'm disappointed because our coffee
traveler box is this
it's 96 fluid ounces
so this peels off which is nice this is
finer than ours
i like that one look this is like
[Music]
we got this boring box look at this
ugh
it's like a caveman
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at starbucks in japan
and here is everything you can get at a
u.s starbucks you cannot get in japan
holy
a bit of clarification we know that
starbucks will customize drink orders
and there's thousands of variations of
special secret menu items plus now
thanks to tic tac there are endless new
drinks so these are things on the
official starbucks menu in japan and the
us so japan starbucks update their menu
very often so by the time this video is
released
they might not be available
sorry
this one is called gold peach
frappuccino
[Music]
i really love peach and this is good
seven out of ten
noise
gold pineapple frappuccino pink frozen
lemonade and passion tea
it's a little bit sour use citrus and
tea
it's the worst
what happened to you
one out of ten
hojicha classic latte so hojicha is
roasted japanese green tea that
originated in kyoto 100 years ago
this is good
fantastic i'll give this
nine out of ten
chai chocolate frappuccino
what
too sweet
espresso affogato so affogato is the
process of pouring espresso shot onto
ice cream
[Music]
again it's too sweet
we've got
dark mocha chip cream
i'm so sorry i spilt most of it the last
one we've got
mango passion tea
and as you can imagine this has strong
mango taste
i feel like i'm hitting the wall here
guys
and you know what would help that
the us does not have as many exclusives
as they do in japan at least not as
frequently but at the time of shooting
this it is the fall you know that means
starbucks usa fans pumpkin spice latte
every fall
the entire country
loses their mind and they go buy
pumpkins and they get themselves this
which is pretty much a latte that tastes
like pumpkin pie
as basic as it is it is pretty good
starbucks has decided to introduce a new
fall beverage to their lineup and that
is this the apple crisp macchiato let's
check it out
[Music]
what is this oh man that's terrible
what's wrong with you guys you thought
this can compete with the pumpkin spice
latte not at all does it sound like i'm
like losing my mind
because i'm like
really cute up right now
i'm going to do my best to pretend like
i'm not unhinged starbucks in the u.s is
this
moving on flat white
what is a flat white
this is a flat white
frappuccinos
strawberry funnel cake frappuccino
that is really sweet
and a scale of one to ten that gets like
ten joes
jozio's that's how i'm writing them i
cannot imagine any time of the day
wanting that but wtmoc what is that
eight years
chai
cream oh god come on the caramel ribbon
crunch
yeah it's still really bad
java chip frappuccino
nope last one thank you god double
chocolatey chip cream frappuccino
[Music]
that's not nearly as chocolatey as the
other one that's like less chocolate and
there's double on the title and we also
got
limited tea this one is called youth
berry
so youth berry is citrus white tea
featuring mango pineapple and acai
wow
so should be healthy and next one we
have roasted green tea we drink this on
a daily basis with breakfast
lunch dinner
anytime you want
it's our go-to drink also in the u.s you
can get iced black teas can't get those
in japan i don't know why you can get
these varieties an iced royal english
breakfast tea latte tea
sucks so i have very low expectations
for this
expectations met the next one you have
here is an iced london fog tea i don't
know what makes it foggy
i don't know and you can also get an
iced matcha lemonade other ice black
teas i cannot get my hands on is the
iced guava black tea and iced peach
green tea oh i bet that peach one's
pretty good cold brews and nitro cold
brews you can get yourself a nitro cold
brew right here
and also a salted caramel cream cold
broom
vanilla sweet cream cold brew when i say
i was taking a sip of everyone i'm
taking a sip everyone i'm like
caffeine drunk
i bet that was good four hours ago you
get yourself an iced
shaken espresso is that what this is
does it sound like i'm like losing my
mind
[Music]
all right the honey almond milk flat
white
it's so terrible it tastes plasticky
so here is starbucks origami starbucks
origami is one cup drip coffee system so
it's got six origamis
and this is what it looks like
you unfold it
like this
so you just put this over a cup
and let's add some hot water
easy peasy japanese
and starbucks coffee is served
refreshers
refreshers
what are refreshes you ask i'm not quite
sure they look like juice oh it's like
stuff floating in these fruit and stuff
kiwi starfish no star fruit
that'd be worth their starfish in this
these were a good idea good call
starbucks ooh mango dragon fruits here
we go
blended strawberry lemonade
very good and this is the strawberry
side lemonade refresher
not as good iced pineapple matcha i
don't want this at all
so here is all the food you can only get
at starbucks in japan
so many
here's exclusive food you can get in the
u.s you can't get in japan
breakfast sandwiches i'm going in turkey
bacon sandwich double smoked bacon
cheddar and egg i think yes impossible
breakfast sandwich sausage egg and
cheese
classic
spinach feta wrap
oh yeah
this is the bacon gouda
sandwich you get yourself an avocado
spread
these little guys are egg bites bacon
and greer egg white roasted red pepper
also these that i bet are not any good
the kale and portobello mushroom egg
bites no thanks now moving on to bagels
so what they were able to give me was
cinnamon raisin
plain bagel
you can also get cheese onion and garlic
bagels everything bagels and sprouted
grain bagels and of course they come
with a cream cheese spread so i've got
this
shrimp avocado salad wrap
consider chicken salad so it's a root
vegetable chicken salad wrap
onion
pepper pan and onion
we've got caesar chicken focaccia
grilled vegetable and soy beans hambagu
hambagu is like hamburger beef patty
nice combination i didn't expect that so
let's go to the next one egg sandwiches
pork patty and english muffin egg and
ham sandwich
[Music]
sandwich
it's got chicken
tomato sauce
smells nice
and next one
big sausage
we got the crispy grilled cheese should
i even open it it's just grilled cheese
right bread and cheese you get it
the tomato
mozzarella panini
turkey pesto sandwich
are we gl are we happy i did that ham
and swiss panini oh the chicken caprese
panini yeah now we're talking
yeah that's right got the italian flag
in one sandwich right there uh this one
is the chicken bacon panini let's open
it up
you can also get yourself protein boxes
there's a bunch of them the one i wanted
didn't have any you can also get a
chicken and quinoa protein bowl
so here we've got baked goods all right
so let's start with this one it's a
biscuit
we've got this waffle which really looks
great this cute
strawberry cake pump
it's just like art
red bean paste and
butter a red bean is really popular in
japan i know it's kind of strange but
when you come to japan
please try this alright next one we've
got this
matcha
cake which looks very beautiful it makes
me wanna post this on instagram lemon
cake also looks great the chocolate
scone
and
tea scone
are you going to put hari's face on this
hello harry
and next one we've got
baked cheese tart this is so cute look
how small it is cake pops yeah their
cake pops are big eyes are tiny double
chocolate brownie
chocolate chip cookie
and although they're pretty popular they
were out when we went in you can get
yourself a marshmallow dream bar
croissants
croissants almond croissant
butter croissant
here we go chocolate croissant
hammond swiss croissant loaves and cakes
banana nut loaf this is the pumpkin loaf
cinnamon coffee cake
soybean the iced lemon loaf
cheese danish blueberry muffin
and of course blueberry scone can we get
harry's face on that
so here we've got packaged foods so this
one is avocado cream cheese tortilla
chips
i will definitely get this with beer no
coffee i need a beer
let's go to the next one in japanese we
say baa mokuhen but this is german right
[Music]
but i'm curious
this matcha
it has really strong much flavor i love
this wow
thank you for coming into my life
chocolate and nuts for timber
and this one is cheese
and fruits protein bar if you take a
bite
you're gonna be
so we've got this
yogurt and banana granola this one right
here is
berry yogurt and berry granola
[Music]
we got here they got their
barbecue chips
hippies organic chickpeas
popcorn
yes
organic fruit puree just eat the fruit
that grow in the tree i put in plastic
first
almonds ooh chocolate covered espresso
beans biscottis
madelines and
sweet potato chips that wasn't enough
you can also get pre-packaged shortbread
cookies dark chocolate grams rip van
waffles and justin's dark chocolate
peanut butter cups sorry justin they
weren't there
so here we've got this dessert section
it all looks great right let's start
with this oreo cookie cake
cinnamon bun
chocolate donut oreo cookie doughnut
with this white chocolate
glazed donut
it's so sticky we've got this jeremy
soup
peach tart and this one is
lemon tart we've got this banana cake
and next one cheesecake
all right so last one they've got
strawberry tart which looks very great
but i don't have sweet tooth so i'm
going to give all of these to my friends
in japan a venti latte with non-fat milk
is 205 calories 0.6 grams of fat
30.2 grams of carbs 20.6 grams of
protein
280 milligrams of sodium and
225 milligrams of caffeine
in the u.s the same venti cafe latte
contains 170 calories 0.4 grams of fat
25 grams of carbs 16 grams of protein
190 milligrams of sodium and 115
milligrams of that sweet sweet caffeine
our venti mocha has
541 calories
too much arventi mocha has 450 calories
ah yes
venti milk
adult hot chocolate this is a venti
caramel frappuccino in japan ours has
487 calories it looks really bad so
i'm going to put
whipped cream
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
itadakimasu
[Music]
george your whipped creams look a little
wimpy there buddy gotta do how we do in
the usa check this out
boom
take that environment in the u.s ours
has less calories only
470. i brought reusable straws
i don't get it this is so bad
what about the cost this venti
frappuccino is 627 yen or
5.69 us
can you put the price down please in the
u.s a camel frappuccino is
5.45 which is around 600 japanese yen
it's kind of close but you must consider
the us venti is four fluid ounces bigger
so let's do that math
looks like it's a bit cheaper in the us
so
here is my favorite frappuccino
this is called matcha frappuccino do you
have this in the u.s
yes george we do in fact have the matcha
frappuccino here in the us too i don't
recall putting that in the script so
i think you pulled a fast one and got us
to buy you a frappuccino so
enjoy
it
this is delicious
excellent
[Music]
japan starbucks doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support
but as of today they haven't gotten back
to us what are you doing in starbucks
you know just respond to george
so here is what we do know our
cappuccino is made of espresso steamed
milk and foam milk
in the u.s our cappuccino is made up of
milk and brewed espresso not a lot of
info in this section going on something
that's not a lot we don't appreciate
being left on red starbucks our caramel
frappuccino is made of blended eyes with
milk whipped cream
real caramel and espresso
i taste the way perfume smells you know
in the u.s our caramel frappuccino is
made up of ice milk carrageenan
vanilla syrup coffee obviously and the
caramel syrup is made up of sugar water
natural flavor citric acid
potassium potassium sorbet salt
monodiglycerides soy lecithin and
sulfates a japanese caramel macchiato
contains vanilla syrup milk espresso and
original caramel sauce and ours in the
u.s contains milk brewed espresso
vanilla syrup which is made of sugar
water natural flavors potassium sorbet
citric acid corn syrup butter cream salt
mono diglycerides soy lecithin and
sulfates
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pizza hut in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
in japan a pizza hut pizza comes in
three sizes the smallest comes in a my
box order and is approximately 15
centimeters
[Music]
our small can only be made on a
gluten-free crust check it out looks
like something you would get in your
high school cafeteria and it measures 10
inches or 25.4 centimeters our next size
up is a medium which is 26
centimeters going to take this little
guy
this pizza is so good dude
and our large pizza is 14 inches or 35.5
centimeters
this my box pizza deal includes fries
and chicken nuggets for 1080 yen or at a
basket cheesecake for
1290 yen
or
get three my boxes for 3 000 yen and you
can get a free style menu item like a
1.5 liters of coca-cola also for those
wanting a little alcohol you can get a
my box deal with an alcoholic beverage
for
1100 yen it's called
being tipsy
[Music]
now we're going to the boxes baby
our next size up is a 13 dinner box it
is a medium one topping pizza bread
sticks and cinnamon sticks this is the
best idea if i had to go into an office
this would be my briefcase this is what
i take to work every day
now you're probably thinking ah joe i
want more food in a box well pizza hut
of course has you covered with the big
dinner box um
oh it is the big dinner box this is
two one topping pizzas with wings or
breadsticks that's what i get of course
you could also get pasta and breadsticks
you can also get k poppas and
breadsticks or just a third pizza all
for 23.99 to 24.99 man dinner is served
you can get chicken on the wall
in two pieces four pieces and eight
pieces that's really cute japan two
wings in the u.s our wing orders start
at 6 12 18 and the biggest order you can
get 36.
well that's that's the hardest wing
street you gotta hire a spice expert
because this is nothing dude i've had
spicier lacroix
here is a japan large basic pizza
we call our cheese pizza basic and it is
2030 yen or
18.39 us and it has a surface area of
754.77
centimeters so that is about 0.024
or
2.63 yen per square centimeter the u.s
large cheese pizza is 13.99
or
1544 japanese yen it has a surface area
of
989.9 square centimeters which breaks
down to
.014 cents per square centimeter or
1.54 japanese yen much cheaper here in
the u.s so here are two large basic
pizzas this one right here is hand
tossed dough and this one right here is
a palm pizza here are two large u.s
cheese pizzas one of them has the pan
crust and one of them has the hand toss
crust both are the same size and the
same price we want to find out which
gives you more pizza for your money
let's weigh a slice of each and compare
go
so winner is
ham toss no
oh wow that's like that's crazy how good
i did just here
same price 25 more pizza
[Music]
look at this
here's everything you can get at
japanese pizza hat you cannot get in the
u.s and here is everything you get at a
u.s pizza you can't get in japan japan
makes cooking pizzas okay
so i got everything on here in half and
half and a medium size
on hand tossed grass all right so let's
start with this one so i got this toku
uma bulgogi tokuguma means special
delicious so it's special delicious
bulgogi and this one is menta potato
mayo bacon menta means spicy cold roll
and it looks good
so next one we've got double shrimp with
special lobster sauce and this one is
ground barbecue asparagus bacon and this
one is potato sausage mayo
next one we've got crumbling
food
pork and next one spicy pulled pork
selected cheese and thick cut iberico
and this one is super supreme mexican
carapeno kara means it's like spicy so
spicy jalapeno on there and next one is
snappy potato sausage
and this one is green and yellow veggie
pizza shrimp mayo men daisy
and this one is addictive anchovy and
black olive first exclusive u.s pizza
pizza is this one right here is the meat
lovers pizza look at this thing you see
that this thing is pepperoni italian
sausage ham
bacon seasoned pork and beef that's
every meat that's every meat in the
store i think uh this one right here is
the hawaiian chicken pizza this
looks like one bite would like send me
to my grave this at least has a
vegetable on it
and the green peppers were a mistake
this one right here chicken bacon
parmesan
chicken bacon tomatoes and a parmesan
crust oh yeah dude look at the crust on
this they bake the cheese right in the
crust i just love that pizza it's like
we gotta cover the every surface with
cheese god forbid
you can take a bite doesn't have cheese
in it
in japan you can get a pizza with four
different topping areas called the four
series
so let's start with this one
it's called gochisso4 gochiso means
feast
and next one we've got bulgogi festa
four
so let's move on to the next one we've
got
numbers 4 lovers
what
is this for this beef it's gonna be
horrible
and this one is called kodawari four
kodawari means authentic
and this one in front of me is gourmet
mania 4.
what did i do to you pizza hut it's
burnt
look at this
all right next one
and the last one is classic or this is
classic
yes
this one right here the backyard
barbecue pizza barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce i think and it comes with a
barbecue honey shall i i think i shall
oh yeah i think i'm gonna like this
don't sleep on the pizza at honey
barbecue this is really good i think
this is buffalo chicken pizza
tangy buffalo sauce
exact opposite problem i think the sauce
ruins this too strong skip the sauce so
this one right here is a japan only
pizza so this is a pizza with uh
sausage crust with bulgogi teriyaki
chicken
camembert cheese gouda cheese green
chili sauce shrimp squid tuna mayo
broccoli
corn
basil sauce and anchovies
too much but let's give it a try look at
this
it's too much
[Music]
it's disgusting
in the first place
i hate anchovies
don't put anchovies
it's just
i picked out that pizza for you george
sorry my man gotta do it for the show
here is a usa only pizza it is a pizza
with toppings and sauces and cheeses you
can only get in the u.s and not in japan
first got the gluten-free crust remember
that that really sad looking crust uh we
can have a creamy garlic parmesan
barbecue or buffalo sauce as a base i
went with the creamy garlic parmesan got
meatballs banana peppers and for the
crust i pretty sure i want the garlic
parmesan
[Music]
it's not awful
when you order food and you're like
really hungry so something sounds like
it's gonna be really good but then we
start eating you're like i think i
screwed up this is definitely like
descriptive
so here we've got japan's exclusive size
we've got chicken nuggets and this is
four pieces eight pieces 16 pieces and
we also have plain flavor and spicy
flavor let's try this
please
this is
everything is plain
spicy very spicy nuggets
and next one we've got honey cheese
balls so cheese balls there and we've
got honey syrup so next one we've got
japanese style pasta chicken so this
chicken is marinated in soy sauce and
rolled in potato starch instead of wheat
flour and deep fried let's talk about
u.s exclusive sides can't get these in
japan pizza hut also got pasta referred
to at one point is pasta hut you can get
two of these baked pastas at our pizza
huts one is the tosca
toscani what
would i say
fine
no tuscany is to us and why they sell
this one with t-u-s-c-a-n-i
no come on i'm looking it up keep wrong
now with pizza hut get a family size to
scanning pasta
in your face
just an absolute abuse of italian
culture here is the toscani chicken
alfredo pasta and the toscani meaty
marinara pasta if i can't put a fine
enough point on it i do not want to eat
this at all this looks like a tv dinner
like this is what you eat in your
apartment sitting on a folding chair one
light bulb hanging from the ceiling
eating this just right out of the oven
staring at a wall looking at like
cockroaches running up and down your one
window has a view of a brick wall the
calendar on the walls from three years
ago nobody wants this
k-pop
what are k-pop as you ask i don't know
they got jalapenos and stuff in them so
they're kind of like spicy tater tots
these to me are like quintessential
pizza hut sides we got breadsticks and
we got cheese sticks they both come with
the marinara sauce we also have a
marinara sauce you guys can have
sauce talk so here is extra sauces so if
you want you can get green chili sauce
or
honey syrup so the wing street wings you
can get a pizza hut also come in
exclusive flavors you can't get in japan
here all the sauces
spicy garlic is really good joe's sauce
seal of approval teriyaki this seems
like a no-brainer but we're not going to
leave it to chance
no
oh
that's not correct this is terrible it
doesn't pass garlic parmesan oh look
there's like parmesan like on top of it
oh
yeah
that might be the best one
lemon pepper dry rub why
do i have to apply it
yeah not into that man i don't get it i
know what drake's going on about man
lemon pepper's not very good crucify me
internet i don't like lemon pepper dry
rub wings should i i think maybe i
should be rubbing it that's what i'm
doing wrong
is that too much
whoops yep you're right too much
that's good also sauces real quick we
got blue cheese we got ranch
so here is japan's exclusive desserts
here we've got
basque cheesecake we've got lady burton
vanilla ice cream
and last one we've got lady burton
chocolate ice cream desserts we got him
in the u.s you can get yourself this a
set of six cinnabon cinnamon rolls this
is the
triple chocolate brownie i'm starting to
lose it guys all that pizza it just hit
me this right here is the ultimate
chocolate chip cookie this is pretty
funny they should cut this like a pizza
cinnamon sticks they also come with a
thing of icing
maybe my obituary photo
i can't believe how good that is this is
the cinnabon thing i want to try it now
since i had it before i want to see that
compares to that
cinnabon is still better
in japan our fountain drinks are
coca-cola products in the u.s our soft
drinks are pepsi products you know what
that means
this is soda wars
in japan we have
coke coke zero
and fanta grape and green tea
orange juice look at this face
[Music]
it has light orange taste classic pepsi
cherry pepsi diet pepsi orange oh yeah
crushed right yeah orange crush mountain
dew and of course sierra mist which is
like mountain dew only
so much worse
so a full pizza is 2256
calories 112.8
of your daily recommended value
too many calories
in the us our large cheese pan pizza has
eight slices and each slice is 360
calories so for the total pizza that's
2880 calories that's 144
of your daily calories and both the fat
and the sodium are each over 200 percent
of your daily allowance japan splurge
pepperoni spring with plum bread crust
is 228 calories per slice or
2736 calories for the entire thing which
is 136.8
percent of your daily calories
even more calories
this is a large u.s pepperoni with the
pan crust that's a thick guy
one slice 370 calories that makes the
whole pizza 2
930 calories and that is 146.5
percent of your daily allowance now i
would like to point out that the large
pepperoni pizza is the most popular
pizza hut pizza in the us but not japan
online it rakes about the 14th most
popular in japan one of the pizzas we
enjoy
is the seafood mix
it's one of pizza hut's best sellers for
over 20 years wow
the japan's most calorific pizza is the
large toku uma bulgogi
and i forgot to order large tokuma
bulgogi sorry about that but this one is
toku uma bulgogi
and this one is smaller but large sliced
pizza is
285 calories which makes the entire
large pizza on plum breadcrust
3420 calories
3420 calories
in the u.s our most calorific pizza is
the meat lovers i also was supposed to
get the large this is a medium if
someone graphics could just make this
pizza much bigger or me much smaller one
slice is 470 calories making the total
pizza which should be eight slices
3760 calories that's more than double
your daily fat and triple your daily
sodium i am a glutton for punishments
but i'm not going to bite into this
pizza it looks like a knife
there's a few ingredients to watch out
for at the pizza huts in the u.s one is
an ingredient found in our salad
croutons it is called azo
dicarbonamidate
azo azo dicarbonid
or
ada it is a substance used for making
vinyl foam plastics for things like yoga
mats and it's also in our croutons i'm
not quite sure why the use of this
additive surprisingly enough is not
permitted in japan what
that's just horrible
both yoga mats and salads have a
connection to health but u.s salad
proteins have actually plastic yoga mat
plastic
how ironic
also in the u.s you're going to want to
watch out for yellow number five aka
tartrazine which appears in these
cinnabon mini rolls oops already ate one
according to the european union this
chemical quote may have an adverse
effect on activity and attention in
children and quote it is banned in the
eu it's not banned here in america and
it is at least not allowed at any of the
pizza huts in japan totally you can
totally get this here in america
let's get some deficit on that attention
may have adverse effect on activity and
tension in children i mean it's having a
horrible effect to my attention as an
adult
i stopped paying attention to what was
coming out of my mouth moments ago so
the do got yellow number five as well
orange crush has yellow number six and
red number forty remember those are bad
too
all the color things are bad i have to
say this is also terrible why the hell
american fast food chains put harmful
chemicals into their foods
do they make their food in a chemistry
laboratory or something
use the kitchen
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between subway and japan and
the u.s this is food wars
[Music]
in japan our sandwiches come in three
sizes this one
is regular
and here we've got
fulong sub and
this one right here is
party tray this is party tray a which is
three regular sandwiches cut into 12
pieces or we can also get a purty tray
that's three full long subs in the us
you have three sizes six inch foot long
and the party tray this is five foot
longs cut into three sections giving us
15 sandwiches not enough partying that
part of platter subway's got you covered
here in the us you can also get a three
foot party sub
whoa
yes yes
time to give this sandwich an exam
dude are you kidding me look at this
i'm saying ham i'm seeing turkey i'm
seeing cheese
and also we have a giant sub let me show
you
oh
i got this
and this is what it looks like
this is too big
[Music]
in japan our fountain drinks come in
three sizes
this one is small
and medium
large
here in the us subway the website says
it is small but i talked to the subway
manager and they assured me they don't
have a small so apparently art fountain
drinks are just two sizes medium
which makes no sense because there's no
small
and large
[Music]
at subway i had to fill up myself
the fountain drinks which of course i
don't mind so any inaccuracies rest on
my shoulders and my shoulders alone
40 what not even close and that was like
i filled this up to the brim i'm looking
through this i'm seeing 33 maybe we'll
be generous look at them 34. they still
missed it by six
six fluid ounces you guys are skimping
on us
you get a good shot of that is that real
is that really six missing ounces do we
think that six ounces of fluid roasting
there
you better believe i'm on a high horse
right now this is infuriating i'm really
hungry that has a lot to do with it too
on the surface both country sandwiches
look the same but we wanted to get a
closer look here we have a foot long on
white turkey with lettuce tomato black
olives and onions all right i've got the
same one so i'm gonna weigh this
wow so pretty close
scientific accuracy is really important
in the food wars so
now let's open it up and see what's
inside
huh only a 10 gram difference but ours
had a lot more turkey and a lot less
vegetables
[Music]
so here are all the subway menu items
you can get in japan but not in the us
and here is everything you get a u.s
subway you cannot get in japan so let's
start with new exclusive sandwiches so
here we've got thunder chicken sandwich
the chicken itself is tender
nine out of ten congrats
so next one we've got
tokumori tandoori chicken sandwich
tokumori means extra large so extra
large pondering chicken sandwich
we've got spicy egg shrimp
so next one we've got
chocolates chicken and cheese sandwich
this is not good
it doesn't have any taste
man what the fudge
so first thing i have this huge pile of
sandwiches here i'll just try and do
some hits here is of course steak and
cheese
buffalo chicken
yeah i don't know maybe it's because
they put all the veggies on here too
they kind of just did
the standard ones that i don't think
this looks very good ooh the cali turkey
looks like spinach on here oh and bacon
yeah okay
not bad they're ruined with the
cucumbers the cold cut combo this is
like the sandwich right if we were
playing family feud and the category was
subway sandwiches i feel like the cold
cut combo would be number one right oh
the baja steak everybody straight from
baja california
you know their blast
now try their steak
everyone in the room just groaned
[Laughter]
i have to know how far is that bathroom
here
they really loaded with the vegetables
again
why would you want all these gross
veggies and i want the meatball and i
want the sauce and the cheese i don't
want
cucumbers
maple sandwich is ruined i'm sneaking a
meatball
yeah the italian bmt
come on this is like the most popular
one so you get the meat there nice
looking meat right glad nice looking
meat they lift up the meat boo
boo
who ruined the sandwich of vegetables it
is the spicy italian
looks like the bmt but yeah dude in
subway's defense these sandwiches were
made what three hours ago at this point
so here are japan's exclusive regular
menu items so let's start with this
pizza bacon italiana
itadakimasu
i would rate this
seven out of ten
so next one we've got prosciutto
mascarpone
shrimp avocado
and i love
avocado
next we've got
turkey bacon egg
turkey
as you can see bacon right here
an egg paste
vimeo
it's not that great
and next we've got
chili chicken sandwich
this
is
terrible
how dare you
okay
i'm getting full but
let's keep going here we got
avocado vegetables
[Music]
next we've got
egg sandwich
all right one thing i have to mention is
that most of these sandwiches can be a
solid so if you like salad go ahead but
jill
wouldn't get this for sure
what did subway get a panini press or
something like look at these they took
these sandwiches and like grilled them
or whatever okay this one right here is
the bmt
so i'm just guessing for the melts
they do it on the white bread and they
add a bunch of cheese and they just
grill it right i mean i can't even open
it's like it's locked
buffalo chicken melts maybe there's less
vegetables in it so maybe i do want this
and i don't realize it steak and cheese
a philly cheesesteak right yeah i know
this one i know this one
tuna melts
turkey milk yeah i guess i mean i gotta
say like i haven't tasted them but the
effort in these are just like what are
you guys doing i mean they just like
flatten them
ham melts
what's sp again
it should be s-i but it's sp for spicy
right that's why i'm like wait a second
is this the spaghetti one we've been
talking about
meatball melts what do they do they
flatten the meatballs in there right
it's better less vegetables right this
is the chicken bacon melt
so this is the japan only sandwich
everything on here you can't get in the
us it's a six inch on sesame bread with
tundra chicken mascarpone cream cheese
egg salad shrimp chili sauce and wasabi
soy sauce
this is a mystery sandwich itadakimasu
i said wasabi soy sauce right i got
wasabi attack
it's hard to me it's got too many
flavors and it makes me confused
this here is the usa only sandwich a
sandwich comprised of only ingredients
you get in the united states and not in
japan so let's start with the jalapeno
cheese bread as meatballs american
cheese pepper jack cheese provolone
cheese banana peppers god spinach ranch
sriracha and pepperoni
here we go
oh it's actually pretty good
i really like this dude oh cool it's not
too spicy the jalapeno breads really
good the meatballs and the pepperoni
work really well together like i said
the banana peppers are actually welcome
in this it kind of makes a little
sweeter then they're gonna bite yeah
subway put this on your menu
this is really good i challenge you all
the viewers in the united states start
ordering this sandwich let's put the
pressure on subway to make this uh make
this like a featured sandwich this is
good
so here we've got snack sandwiches but
this one right here is
uncle sandwich and anko is a staple of
traditional japanese sweets the taste
can be enjoyed alone or as a compliment
to other japanese flavors such as matcha
and here we've got
anko and mascarpone
i have an announcement to make subway
has breakfast i'm just as surprised as
all you specifically they have four
breakfast sandwiches here in the u.s a
bacon egg and cheese a black forest ham
egg and cheese egg and cheese and steak
egg and cheese i don't know which one is
which i think this is the steak egg and
cheese
oh it's flatbread too so i can kind of
this looks like a cartoon look at this
look at the eggs
are you kidding me with this
in a subway in the u.s you can get just
about any one of their sandwiches as a
protein bowl from what i can tell that's
their way of calling this a salad so you
know my feelings on salad
i hate them just an example though we
got what looks to be a turkey one
everything that comes in a sandwich
which is instead of bread this bowl then
once you're done you can throw it in the
ocean
kill a sea turtle who cares right
it's a waste it's an absolute waste just
eat a sandwich like a normal person
there's nothing wrong with bread just
eat it it's a sandwich yeah and it's
like the shredded lettuce too it's not
like
you know like leafy lettuce or spinach
it's that shredded they put in the
sandwich
so here is japan's exclusive size this
one right here is coral poro potatoes
original flavor and next one we've got
coco cotta potatoes triple cheese flavor
coral coral potatoes herb salt flavor
the korokoro means it's like rolling
over and over like
rolling over and over and last one we've
got
corn cream chowder
yeah chips
chips
chips get yourself to bake lays
i mean
the undisputed chip champion in the
united states right here baby nacho
cheese doritos
a favorite a classic glaze we just want
to see what potato chips are like in the
50s get yourself a bag of classic lace
vickies jalapeno and lime cracked pepper
i don't think i've had the lime cracked
pepper
these are so good
sun chips i hate sun chips
here's a side that you can get in the
u.s you can't get in japan i'm gonna go
muscle man's applesauce
so here is japan's exclusive drinks
this one right here is ascii and pepsi
melon soda oolong tea which is chinese
tea iced coffee soy cocoa
and this one right here is vegetable and
fruit juice which has 11 kinds of
vegetables and three kinds of fruits and
this one right here is pepsi zero and
this one is mocha that's coffee olay and
this one right here is ginger ale and
soy latte soy mango mango orange mango
juice mocha and milk tea cocoa
hot black tea
and herb tea
in the u.s as you notice we have coke
and coke products at our subways so we
have coke and they also have to go
bottles so i went ahead and got diet
coke
sprites
and gatorade the fruit punch all right
sauce talk sauce talk
i couldn't get any of them on the side
but we have exclusive sauces here at the
subway in the u.s we can get a red wine
vinegar a yellow mustard a creamy
sriracha a buffalo sauce of course we
also have ranch chipotle southwest
marinara sauce
sweet onion sauce and mvp parmesan
the most valuable parmesan apparently i
was surprised to learn that the japanese
subway doesn't have cookies the cookies
are actually pretty good in the u.s you
can get a chocolate chip cookie an
oatmeal raisin cookie a raspberry
cheesecake cookie and a white chip
macadamia nut cooking alright so let's
move on to japan's exclusive sweets so
let's start with this one chocolate
brownie
we've got
cheese tart
and this one right here is cream soda
float
and this one right here is cream latte
float
and coffee food
[Music]
in japan a six inch turkey sub on white
bread is 261 calories and the us that
same turkey sub is 270 calories so
pretty close but i did notice ours has
much less sodium like 26 percent less
our 6 inch tuna sub is 361 calories in
our tuna it's 430 so a little more but
much more fat i have not eaten turkey a
tuna anything on purpose ever it smells
like cat food don't you think it smells
i guess most cat food is tuna so yeah
this looks super gross but i have to try
it right
let's see if like my distaste is
misplaced
no
i hate that man
do you like calories in japan our most
calorie fake sandwich is the pizza bacon
italiana 1 6 inch is
436 calories in the u.s our most
calorific sandwich is the chicken and
bacon ranch just six inches of this bad
boy is 500 calories so footlong is a
thousand calories
in japan our regular sandwich with a
small drink and small serving of
potatoes the total calories for this
meal is
498 calories in the u.s a six inch
turkey sandwich with a small drink which
the subway i went to said they do not
have and a bag of chips i went with the
classic lace is 750 calories
in japan this meal total is 790 yen or
7.23 cents u.s in the us that same meal
is 9.14 or about
998.26 japanese yen roughly twenty six
point four percent increase
in japan we focus on having a healthy
diet or chol cuts meals tokatsu means
having a healthy diet that contains a
lot of dietary fiber in order to keep
your intestinal environment healthy and
it's getting common in japan to have
tall cats meals at home or even at
restaurants because a lot of japanese
people have a constipation problem due
to a lot of stress and lack of exercise
so subway offers a special meal called
chokats chicken and cheese sandwich
which contains a lot of dietary fiber so
it's going to help you return to regular
bowel movements and you can start your
day with a number two
so we don't have anything like that but
i can only speak for myself that if
you're experiencing
constipation in the united states
may i recommend the steak and cheese at
subway
the subway in japan does not disclose
all the raw ingredients but they did
provide the main raw ingredients for
their breads japan subway flatbread
contains wheat flour
yeast vegetable fat and oils
skim milk powder
wheat protein
salt
sugar
barley malt powder
etc well our subway in the us does give
us the ingredients and our flatbread
contains all of events now there's a few
similar ingredients and there's a bunch
that are pretty close that etc in the
japan flatbread that gives me pause i
mean if that's supposed to represent all
of this other stuff that is a huge
dot dot dot or to be continued or yadda
yadda yadda that japan's throwing at
their uh their customers i mean if the
america
has proven anything it's like you can
tell us what's in the food we don't care
we'll still eat it so i don't know
what's up with the etc guys subways tuna
was a bit controversial here in the u.s
starting in january where a class-action
lawsuit made false claims about their
tuna meet the drama continue when a new
york times article claiming to have had
a lab analyzed 60 inches worth of subway
tuna shared the results saying they
could not identify a species of fish and
no amplifiable tuna dna was present in
the sample subway responded of course
saying it uses 100 wild caught tuna and
even launched a website subway
tunafacts.com
to give everyone a clear and transparent
look into their tuna process
furthermore usa today did their own
fact-checking and had its doubts about
how the times tested the tuna samples
and pointed out the lab tested for five
tuna species out of 15 and concluded the
tuna was too processed or that there was
no tuna dna different tests have
detected tuna in subway sandwiches and
experts say canned tuna can become
denatured when cooked then i did my own
scientific research to find out what
denature means and the scientists at
dictionary.com said dear joe thanks for
reaching out to dictionary.com the word
denature means to destroy the
characteristic properties of a protein
or biological micromolecule by heat
acidity or other effects that disrupt
its molecular confirmation they went on
to say for further definition inquiries
please just use the search function on
the home page as that is what's there
for don't email us so
believe we want
another subway ingredient controversy
that's a bit more clean cut at least for
the good people ireland is that an irish
court ruled subway cannot call their
bread bread due to its high sugar
content in ireland for bread to be
considered bread the amount of sugar in
the dough must be two percent the
flour's weight subway is bread however
the sugar content is nine point two
percent
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between taco bell in japan and the u.s
this is footworks
in japan taco bell standard tacos come
in orders of one
two tacos with fries
and a drink
or you can get five pack
or you can get 10 pack
in the us our standard taco bell tacos
come in orders of one three with a
medium drink or this the twelve taco
party pack check this out
i mean they're not kid ones as a party
you roll into any party
with this
you are you are the party winner right
so this is a beef taco spring he
measures five inches our beef taco
supreme that's falling apart because i'm
an idiot
is exactly five and three-fourths inches
and let's weigh this and it weighs
it weighs 100 grams
looks like about 120 grams and this one
is our burrito in japan and let's
measure it
five inches our bean burrito is six
and three eighths inches long and it
weighs
good
it weighs
220 grams just a a hair over 250 grams
yeah
ours weighs more
hooray
here's our current rough spring
he measures
six inches across let's go
he weighs exactly 250 grams a personal
favorite the crunch wraps
oh man
oh
guys
i mean you get the idea but it's just
it's just like a thing of beauty when
they have the whole thing folded
properly plus also now all my
everything inside's kind of exposed
across
it's exactly
six inches
huh illuminati stuff coming at you six
sides six inches
we're onto them here they come
if we go point to point it is the
less interesting six and a half inches
so we'll lay it
you have no idea how bad i just want to
take a huge bite out of this thing it
weighs a respectable 300 grams that to
me sounds exactly right at the japanese
talk about the biggest menu item is
[Music]
the variety setback
it includes two grilled burritos which
is chicken
and two chick stars which is fried
chicken crunch wrap screen
and here is four crunch tacos which is b
and here is natchez
all for
5 000 yen
or around 45 45.49 us
did george just say 45.49 for the just
the largest menu item that can't be
right that is so much money everything
on this end is 157
just their largest thing it was almost
46 bucks that's wild the biggest single
menu item we have here in the united
states is the before mentioned taco bell
party box this is exactly what it looks
like is a pack of 12 tacos and in
america this runs you
22.99 or around
2526.80 japanese yen
so here is everything
you can only get at taco bell in japan
you cannot get in the u.s and here's
everything you can get at a u.s taco
bell you can't get in japan
probably i'm very confused
i don't know what half of this stuff is
so these are japan's special menu items
but before getting started i gotta
mention one thing is that
i
have never tried taco bell before
this is my first time i'm so excited
george i can't believe this is your
first time trying taco bell uh
congratulations and i'm sorry so here is
naked chicken taco
i don't know why
it's called naked let me try
it
this shell is not a usual taco shell
it's actually
chicken shell
you rock my wall
so here is diy tack kit i'm gonna make
my own special tacos which is called
george's special tacos g s g yo
i'm gonna go with this
crunchy shell
i don't have spoons so i have to do like
this
one more time you gotta be gentle
i'm going to use this one
i have a good idea
i gotcha for some letters
for some cheese
tomato
i prefer
mild
this is what we call gst
itadakimasu
[Music]
george just made his special taco and it
is like the most
average taco he was like he was like
meat cheese tomatoes and so i hate to
break it to you george but you made like
you just made a uh
it's like a soft shell taco what would
my
taco be
what would my joe's
signature
taco bell taco dorito shell right
everyone's not in the head follow me so
far rap in the gordita
right then the steak okay
then
tapatio i don't know if that's on the
menu there that queso from chipotle
that's good right i could put that on
there guacamole there's a taco chain in
the midwest called taco john's and they
have these little potato things called
potato olay so i put some potato olays
from taco john's on there so we have it
then we deep fry it i need a dipping
sauce what would i what would i uh what
if i was to dip what would i dip it in
give me a sauce
sour cream you're out of your mind
terrible what do you think
you guys are terrible you know what i'm
talking about as a ranch we'll go with
ranch
spicy mayo
this guy's criminal over here like
that's taco bell guys get real there's
joe's and only joe's
signature taco get it going there's got
to collab with chipotle and taco john's
usa
exclusive tacos at the taco bell taco
bell
or doritos or both had the brilliant
idea of going why don't we make our
shell
like a dorito
and for some strange reason they still
have non-doritos shell tacos which i
don't understand why because it is far
superior to any other regular taco shell
they have on their menu look at this
thing look at this thing i'm salivating
looking at this nothing including
oranges are this orange naturally this
is just a whole level
of food chemical engineering and i
applaud it doritos taco bell here we go
oh my gosh so good
george you got to come to america you
got to try this chalupa supreme i'm
assuming that's this the black bean
chalupa well we always saw that yeah it
doesn't look like itself the cantina
crispy
melts it has a deep fried shell and the
other nasty beans
all the veggies and then this must be
a crispy melt the gorditas crunches are
they take a regular taco covered in
melted cheese
nacho cheese and then wrap a
tortilla around it taco bell answered my
prayers by making a
gordita crunch that has in fact
the doritos shell inside of it they use
yeah and they use cheese to melt it to
the hard shell best idea ever gotta know
something stuffed in something with
melted cheese is everything i want
is it good yeah are you a vegetarian is
that why you had it
no what would you get not meat at taco
bell
okay i understand all right to each
their own the spicy potato soft taco i
hear from a very good source very
reliable sources this is good so gotta
know
oh god dude
this is good what's the sausage on here
we do not have available the loaded
chicken flatbread
or the loaded black bean flatbread uh
they are on the website they weren't
available here we've got
cheesy core burrito
we've got
cheesy beef burrito we've got
chick star
which is fried chicken crunch wrap
spring burritos i'm already tired
quesorito beefy five-layer burrito
burrito supreme black bean crunch up
supreme cheesy roll did we see the
chicken chipotle melt yeah those one
ripped open was a chicken chipotle melt
so here is japan's only cider menu we've
got crispy chicken our taco bell in the
u.s you can get a side of black beans
and rice or guacamole so here are few
menu items that are the same but so
different between japan and ios our
notches come like this the chips and
toppings
are separate i got
two avocado sauce and tomato
and cheese
and sour cream and in the u.s
and also mexico i assume you get your
nachos with everything already piled on
the chips up until recently i thought
one of the key descriptors of
nachos is that it's chips with stuff
piled on it but in japan
they give you the chips as you can see
and they have like each ingredient in a
cup and you can kind of mix it i think
that is ridiculous this is what nachos i
know this like these are
taco bell nachos they also have the make
your own taco kits and then they get to
make your own
uh nacho kits
but don't do that we call our chips
mexican chips and they are tortilla
chips that are flavored doing a complete
180 i am very jealous that japan has
flavored tortilla chips i like tortilla
chips just fine um the nacho cheese at
taco bell i'm gonna be honest with you
it's just okay but i think flavored
chips with this cheese would actually be
really good we'll take an l on that one
but it's the only one we've taken this
whole video so that's fine
our loaded fries in japan are topped
with beef
and cheese
and sour cream and here in the u.s our
loaded fries
are not existence wasn't on the menu the
one i went at they are on the website i
don't know if it's just a southern
california taco bell thing our load of
fries have beef lettuce ranch red strips
cheese and tomatoes sounds very good
we were supposed to have taco bell
desserts as well
but the store i went to
didn't have them so here's a list
ice cream
premium ice cream
cinnamon tostada
and chocodia
i want to try chocodia
that's all i can say
our desserts we have these little guys
cinnabon delights we all know what
cinnabon is we all like to be delighted
looks like a little munchkin that may or
may not be cinnabun flavored let's find
that together
holy sh so these are japan only drinks
we've got coke and coke zero
drinks sip sip baby look at all these
colorful drinks you eat and drink with
your eyes so i've been told so naturally
the whole color of the banned chemical
rainbow right in front of me here with
every yellow number this red number
there blue in the whatever so
i'm gonna assume none of these are in
japan because of whatever's inside of
them i'm just gonna list i'll just do
like a few hits pepsi we know that right
they got coke we got pepsi see our mist
i hate that so much
baja blast oh god this is mountain dew
baja blast right here more on this in a
moment
oh good god also we have here is
mountain dew kickstarter orange this
actually rules
so this uh urine pantone color beverage
can only mean one thing that it was
swiped up the side of a dewy mountain
ladies and gentlemen mountain dew
i will go to my grave knowing that
flavor all too well i don't know why
this don't have regular fruit punch if
the gatorade the g2 gatorade fruit punch
pink lemonade so i heard
that pink lemonade is just lemonade
that's dyed pink
this is like lemony what's in pink
lemonade that makes it pink it was it
was originally like it was invented by i
think like a traveling circus and they
just did it kind of like to get people
to buy it like it was a novelty it was
pink instead of regular lemon in color
but i'm assuming now they do some they
must do something in pink lemonade to
make a taste
that's
limited what makes pink lemonade
different from lemonade i want to know
our taco bell also has coffee and iced
coffee and although i would never drink
this unsweetened iced tea taco bell's
got breakfast in the u.s and i have to
say i think that their breakfast menu is
fantastic if it looks a little scarce it
is because i don't think they gave me
everything and i'm confused on what some
of these things are because everything's
kind of wrapped they used to have like
uh then they used to have like a waffle
taco maybe maybe i'm just imagining that
they got a cheesy toasted breakfast
burrito
and a cheesy toasted breakfast burrito
with potato and of course they have a
hash brown toasted breakfast burrito
which i think is this hashbrown toasted
breakfast burrito with steak which is
right here and of course the grand
toasted breakfast burrito which is right
here and of course they have the grand
toasted breakfast burrito with steak and
then they have a breakfast crunch wrap
yo
this one has
eggs and potato in it
it looks ridiculous but for real when
these are hot and like 9 30 in the
morning you can't beat this
as a matter of fact
this is so good
you've been sitting out for a couple
hours it's still awesome
taco bell's breakfast is great it's
there no mcgriddles but if a mcdonald's
isn't available i go right to taco bell
breakfast you can also get
hash brown can you see them
breakfast salsas these are really good
orange juice the homies over tropicana
hold it down
let's talk about nutrition in japan a
beef crunchy taco is
164.4 calories it has
87.2 grams of protein
5.5 grams of fat
14.7 grams of carbs and
293 milligrams of sodium in the u.s our
standard beef crunchy taco is 170
calories 8 grams of protein 9 grams of
fat 13 grams of carbs and 310 milligrams
of sodium so we lead in calories fat and
sodium where japan has more protein and
carbs the next one is the chicken
quesadilla
ours has
492 492.51 calories this one has 510
calories one thing to note that in both
countries one of these quesadillas
hovers around half of your daily sodium
sodium at taco bell appears to be such
an issue that the us menu online certain
combos and items like this one right
here are labeled with sodium warnings in
japan a crunchwrap spring has
1290 milligrams of sodium that's 56 of
your daily allowance our crunchwrap
supreme is 52
your daily sodium that's more than half
right man so both countries way too much
sodium are you looking for the most
calories in one menu item in japan
it's our loaded fries one order is
718 calories it has a third of your
daily calories almost half your daily
fat and 66 of your daily
sodium in the u.s the biggest thing you
should look out for are the nachos the
very popular nachos belgrande i love you
guys is 740 calories
1050 milligrams of sodium okay now the
cinnabon delights do have more calories
930 but technically that's a 12 pack
which is supposed to be for four people
i'm certain if you're like me you're
getting 12 and you're not sharing them
some do most don't but obviously the
natchez bell grande is for one person
but the most calories line an item
that's on taco bell's cantina menu which
is only available at certain locations
here in the u.s there you can get
something called the grande beef nachos
which has
1
120
calories which is more than half of your
daily allowance and 68 of your daily
sodium
now it's just not the food at taco bell
you also have to watch out for the
drinks
here it is everyone
30 fluid ounces of mountain dew ba ha
blast a beverage that answers the
question what if we combine mountain
dew's bold refreshing tropical flavor
with crystal meth this totally logical
30 fluid ounces of nightmare fuel is 420
calories very cool and 110 grams of
sugar i'm sorry this stuff is making me
delirious
in the us there are few ingredients in
our taco bell you should look out for
both are in the beverages on the taco
bell's cantina menu first is brominated
vegetable oil aka bvo which is banned in
japan bvo is an emulsifier found in
citrus flavored sodas and is
specifically used with citrus oils and
it's considered a health risk when
ingested in large amounts it was brought
to public attention when it was
discovered in popular beverages like
mountain dew and powerade but due to
public pressure it was removed from coke
and pepsi products in 2014 which is good
now unfortunately you can still find
this ingredient in three cantina menu
freezes the beach berry freeze the
ginger mule freeze and the party punch
freeze luckily they weren't any of the
freezes you find in the regular menu
only on the cantina menu
okay when it comes to citrus flavored
soda we have
cc lemon that's one of the most popular
citrus flavored soda in japan
cc lemon contains the following
sugars which is fructose glucose syrup
and sugar and lemon juice flavoring
vitamin c a sealant
sunflower dye calcium pantothenate
vitamin b6 carotene pigment that's it
see
it doesn't have
brominated vegetable oil it tastes
really good
so that means
you can make it delicious without b v o
the last one party punch freeze also
contains yellow number five aka
tartrazine which is subject to
restrictions outside of the us in places
like the eu and japan as it may have
adverse effect
and activity and attention in children
what the hell you can tell this color is
yellow right
so why don't you use something else that
isn't harmful just like c c lemon see
you soon
see you soon